okay so in this presentation we're going
to go over some of the basic features on
a category of plants known as
gymnosperms and like the picture shows
these are plants that have leaves that
are needle-like and they reproduce by
creating cones like pine cones so let's
go ahead and get started so one of the
major advancements with gymnosperms is
they make seeds gymnosperms are a little
different than the other videos I've
made on ferns and mosses ferns and
mosses do not make seeds but gymnosperms
do and one of the advantages of seeds it
says he seed plants plants that have
seeds they don't depend on water to
reproduce Moss and ferns do Moss and
ferns need water in order for swimming
sperm cells to swim from the the male
what's called the antheridium to the
female archegonium but with seed plants
often they spread their pollen by either
wind or by pollinating animals another
advantage of having seeds is that a seed
itself is it is full of nutrients and so
inside of the seed there's a little baby
embryo there's an embryo of a plant with
a little stored food supply that it will
feed on until the seed cracks open and
the little tiny embryonic leaf begins to
do photosynthesis of course we know that
seeds are often very very hard and we
actually have you know nutcrackers and
stuff to try to break open seeds and sow
seeds offer protection they protect the
embryo that's growing inside and until
the embryo gets to be a certain size
where it will break open from the seed
and begin to grow on its own so that's a
couple of advantages right there of
having seeds another advantage of seeds
is that seeds are often designed to be
dispersed to be spread and so like the
picture shows we have birds birds will
often eat fruits and of course buried
inside of the fruit is a seed and so the
bird will eat the fruit and then fly
away and then a few hours later
the bird goes to the bathroom it takes a
poop and the seeds are carried from the
from where the bird first ate the seeds
until where the bird traveled and in the
the seeds are then left in the bird poop
and so this is one great little
adaptation that plants have to be in
dispersed plants again they they would
have a big disadvantage if they just
fell straight down onto the ground and
landed underneath their parent tree the
parent tree would block all the sunlight
Raab all the nutrients so seeds need
help help the plant be dispersed another
way that seeds help being dispersed is
they often can drift in the wind if
you've ever had dandelion seeds
dandelion I could see in the picture and
you just pluck a dandelion and blow on
the fuzzy little white seeds they'll
blow away in the wind and eventually
land somewhere and grow into more
dandelions and some seeds you'll see
this a little bit later even have little
wings on them these are called
helicopter seeds now they're not
helicopters like manmade helicopters
they don't have a motor they don't they
don't use energy to rotate but when they
fall when the seed falls from the tree a
little gust of wind can cause them the
torille around and they kind of glide
and then they land out on maybe a
hundred feet away from the parent tree
will see more on this in a little bit
so I already talked about in other
videos Group one were seedless and
nonvascular plants and we focused on
moss group two were seedless but they
had a vascular system and we focused on
ferns so today we're going to focus on a
type of plants that's it that's called
gymnosperms and gymnosperms are what we
call are our plants that produce seeds
and they have a vascular system and so
gymnosperms is the big broad name for
these types of plants now there is
another group of plants we'll see in
another video called angiosperms but
this video is really going to focus on
gymnosperms and so one of the defining
features and you saw this on the title
picture at the beginning is that the
leaves of gymnosperms are often very
needle-like it helps reduce their water
loss a lot of them live in very cold
places where water is kind of scarce and
so having real thin leaves like this
prevents them from losing a lot of water
and gymnosperms are very common in the
lumber industry so a lot of the wood
products that we use in building
building supplies comes from from
gymnosperms you can go down to a home
supply shop like Home Depot and you can
go to the lumber section and you can buy
various kinds of lumber such as spruce
spruce is a gymnosperm and you can go
down to a lumberyard and buy spruce and
when the plant is reproducing you may
have often noticed that trees like pine
pine trees produce cones well there's
actually two different kinds of cones
and so there are some cones that produce
pollen these are the male cones there
are some cones that produce eggs these
are the female cones and in the picture
the picture on top shows a male cone the
picture on the bottom shows a female
cone and so we're going to go over how
they reproduce and how we'll talk more
about cones in a few moments but here's
just a nice picture of a male and female
cone a pollen cone for the male and a
seed excuse me a yeah a seed cone a seed
known for the female and so you can see
in this picture somebody's shaken a own
and little seeds are falling out and so
cones will protect the seeds that are
growing inside and so when a sperm and
egg fused together they make the zygote
that zygote will eventually hardened
into a seed and the seed is protected
inside by the cone and so here are some
examples evergreen pine redwood cedar
these are examples of gymnosperms
one thing I want to mention really quick
is that gymnosperms can be subdivided
into three basic or three three a little
more specific categories the picture
here shows one of those categories
called a psych ad and notice how the
cone structure is right in the middle
you know we're not really going to focus
too much on these a second group of
gymnosperms ginko you might you might
know of Ginkgo because it's a it's an
herbal supplement that some people take
to help improve their memory and and so
ginkgo is another of the gymnosperms but
we're really not going to focus on them
either in this video here's the one that
we're going to pay most of our attention
to conifers conifers are for instance
like pine trees pine trees are a great
example of conifers and so these are the
ones we're going to focus our attention
on and when we go over the life cycle of
how gymnosperms reproduce its really
conifers that we're examining so here
again here are the three big broad
category the three I should say
subcategories of gymnosperms the cycads
ginkgo and conifers like I said though
the one we're stressing if you're in my
biology class the one I want you to to
pay extra special attention to are the
conifers okay so let's go over the the
reproductive life cycle you know that
plants in general go through a cycle of
what's called alternation of generations
and let's kind of show you how that
happens in gymnosperms so here's a
common gymnosperm right here and the
note says number one the adult
sporophyte grows in a forest so again in
gymnosperms the sporophyte is the
dominant stage if you come across a
redwood tree what you're looking at is
at the sporophyte stage if you come
across a pine tree what you're looking
at is the sporophyte stage so let's
let's say that this is a pine tree and
and it's growing in the forest
what we're looking at is the adult
sporophyte well because it's an adult it
has male and female cones on it male
pollen cones tend to be clustered in
groups and they tend to be smaller and
female seed cones tend to be a bit
larger let's zoom on in here's a closer
look at the male pollen cones and so
when you see what I meant by they tend
to be the male pollen cones tend to be
clustered together so there's about a
you know a couple dozen in that picture
right there all clustered together when
we look at a zoomed in picture of a
female female seed cones you can see
that there's a couple of them two or
three or four of them grouped together
but these are scattered throughout the
tree I'm only showing one group of male
pollen cones and one group of female
seed cones but there are multiple
patches of male pollen cones on the tree
multiple patches of female seed cones so
here's how it's going to work next
so next we're going to show you that the
male pollen cone the reason it's called
a pollen cone is it's going to release
pollen and pollen is the male
gametophyte member plants alternate
between sporophyte and gametophyte stage
and so here we see pollen is the name of
the haploid stage the gametophyte stage
and in the animation you see little
black dots of being release on a nice
windy day wind will carry pollen and
sometimes they will pollinate themselves
in this animation we're going to have
this tree pollinate and neighbors let's
find a neighboring tree here we go let's
move to the right and find neighboring
tree okay here we have a neighboring
tree and the neighboring tree just
received some pollen from the tree that
we saw to the left and that's what
pollination is pollination is where
pollen from one is transported to
another and so the pollen lands on a
female seed cone well let's go ahead and
zoom on into the seed cone so we can get
a closer look at what's going on let's
zoom on in right now and when we zoom on
in we can see that there are little
there are little wedges in between the
seed cone these little crevasses these
little wedges are called scales and
inside of every scale inside of every
little wedge there is the female
gametophyte so if you notice there's one
female gametophyte there's another and
another and another so a single cone
might hold a dozen a couple dozen female
gametophyte every one of them might be
pollinated so watch
in pollination in pollination here we
see pollen a whole bunch of pollen land
each little individual scale their
received a pollen grain and so if you
have 12 pollens land on 12 female
gametophyte
chances are you're eventually going to
get 12 seeds but let's zoom on into one
single female gametophyte see that
flashing yellow box let's zoom on in
there and take a closer look and when we
do here's what we see one individual
scale and we see that the black outlines
what is known as the female ovule and
the ovule is simply the outer boundary
of the female gametophyte
and so what happens during the process
of pollination there is a big old green
pollen green and so there is a pollen
and it just landed and the black dot in
the middle of the pollen that's a sperm
cell and so we're setting up I hope you
see what we're setting up we're setting
up the process of fertilization and so
now let's look at fertilization sperm is
going to travel from that greenish that
green pollen green watch the animation
that black dot sperm is going to travel
into the egg where as I go will be
created and so once the zygote is
created notice how there's a thick black
line outlining the outside of what is
called the ovule and that is going to
grow into a seed so the that will
protect the zygote that's growing inside
if we zoom back out and take a look at
that cone when we zoom back out and take
a look at the cone you can see hey look
at that
there's a seed in every little wedge and
so one single cone very well can house
multiple multiple seeds well let's zoom
out again let's zoom out again and take
a look at the overall tree and so here's
a female seed cone and so we just saw a
pollen come on in and fertilize and so
now what
well on a nice windy day earlier in the
notes I told you that seeds are often
called helicopter seeds so on a nice
windy day now that the seeds have formed
the cone is going to open and one by one
the seeds are going to begin to fall
from the seed cone watch the animation
and because they have those little
helicopter wings on them they simply
spin away and drift and blow in the wind
and eventually they're going to land on
the ground and hopefully grow into a new
tree let's follow those so here comes a
helicopter seed and it just landed on
the ground well this little helicopter
seed is going to hopefully grow if
conditions are right if it lands in a
nice nice area with lots of sunlight and
good moisture and plenty of water that
little seed is going to grow into a
little young sporophyte and over the
years and of course it'll get bigger
over the years that little young
sporophyte will grow into a bigger and
bigger and bigger and bigger and
eventually become an adult an adult
sporophyte and notice how there are now
cones on this adult sporophyte some of
the cones are male pollen cones some of
the cones are female seed cones and
therefore we restart the cycle the male
pollen cone will release pollen and
restart this whole cycle
okay so there you have it there's a
quick overview of a category of plants
called gymnosperms gymnosperms if you
recall our seed producing and have a
vascular system so go ahead and if
you're in my biology class pause the
video try to answer these questions
bring your answers to me on a separate
sheet of paper I'd be happy to check
them for accuracy good luck